what's up everybody welcome to another  episode of challenge for affinity this  is a series where you challenge us with  our crazy studies related symptoms if  your comment gets picked we'll feature  in our next video and give you a shelter  so make sure you come to the comment  section below so man of Matt wants us to  play with the detached  net not sure if it's gonna work out but  let's try  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  alright next we'll play on three tables  we've made a triangle for them let's try  and play on them  [Music]  [Music]  mattias cos wants us play with a bouncy  ball instead of a table tennis ball  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  stop button  [Applause]  [Music]  oh really  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  thanks for watching guys hope you  enjoyed this episode if you liked it  leave it a thumbs up subscribe here and  watch for previous episodes here until  next time  [Music]  ah